مشاهدينا خريطه المعارك على الارض تنتشر
في العديد من النقاط الساخنه سواء في
العاصمه الخرطوم او خارجها وتدور اكثر
المعارك شراسه في مناطق متعدده من العاصمه
الخرطوم ابرزها مقر القياده العامه للجيش
الواقع في شمال العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر
في محيط مقر القياده وسط انباء متضاربه
حول الجهه المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر
في العاصمه الخرطوم كان مسرحا للاقتتال
بين طرفين وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي
يتواجد في المنطقه الشماليه في العاصمه
وكانت قوه الدعم اعلنت سيطرتها قبل ان
ينفي ذلك الجيش لاحقا وفيوندرمان دارت
الشبكات في محيطهم مبنى تلفزيون بعد
محاوله قوات الدعم السريع السيطره عليه
وفقا للجيش الذي اعلن سيطرته على المبنى
بشكل كامل وبعيدا عن العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه
المره شمال البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه مرويه
التي شهدت اندلاع شراره الاولى للازمه فان
مصير مطار مروي الذي يقع في الجزء الشرقي
من المدينه لا يزال معلقا في ظل اعلان كل
طرف بسطه سيطرته عليه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات